ahora que ya has tenido un poco de
acercamiento a lo que una combo lución
es puedo presentarles el teorema de la
convención o al menos en el contexto de
las ecuaciones diferenciales y de la
transformada de laplace verdad porque
puede haber otros teoremas de
convolución pero bueno solo vamos a
tratar en este tema este es el teorema
de convolución cómo se aplica a la
transformada de laplace y nos dice que
si tengo una función
efe dt y puedo definir su transformada
de la plaza como a efe mayúscula de s ya
lo hemos hecho antes y digamos que tengo
otra función g de t cdti tomó su
transformada de la plaza y que vamos a
llamar por supuesto que desee pero g
mayúscula así que si tú si tuviéramos la
conducción de f
esta es la convención de f
esto bueno por supuesto va a ser una
función que dependa de te verdad lo
vimos en el vídeo pasado con seno y
coseno y demás así que esto como función
de t si tomamos la transformada de la
plaza de esta cosa lo central del
teorema nos dice que la transformada de
la plaza de esta convención de estas dos
funciones es igual al producto de las
transformadas de la plaza es decir es
igual a efe de s por cdc estas
mayúsculas por supuesto
esto puede parecer muy abstracto y a lo
mejor muy duro de manejar pero ustedes
verán que no es tan difícil y en
realidad vamos a hacer una inversa para
transformar con un ejemplo es decir si
esto es cierto podríamos también poner
del lado izquierdo transformada de la
plaza inversa de esto es decir la
convulsión de fg baja que es una función
de t será igual a la transformada
inversa de la plaza de fs por gps
verdad de que no puedo resistir lo voy a
cambiar de colores de fs por gdf ahí
estás ahora
que que se puede hacer con todo esto
bueno podemos tomar la transformada
inversa de la plaza y digamos que
déjenme escribirlo aquí digamos digamos
que ustedes tienen la siguiente
expresión o función que es una hd s una
función que depende de ese digamos 2s
sobre ese cuadrada más uno y todo esto
al cuadrado hicimos algo y digamos que
terminamos de una ecuación diferencial
que tenemos que calcular la transformada
inversa de esta cosa así que queremos
averiguar la transformada inversa de la
plaza de h de s ok la transformada
inversa de esta cosa de ahí así que
queremos averiguar cómo calcular la
transformada inversa de la plaza de esta
expresión de 2 s sobre s cuadrada más 1
y todo esto al cuadrado no quiero que se
pierda nada allí ahora podemos escribir
esto como el producto de dos funciones
de dos que conozcamos vamos a intentar
hacer esto por lo tanto podemos
reescribir esto así que
esta es la transformada inversa de la
plaza de genera escribir esta función yo
puedo reescribir la función en morado
como está ya funcionando cc / s cuadrada
más o no al cuadrado como 2 podemos
escribirlo como 2 por 1 sobre s cuadrada
más 1 y luego todo esto lo multiplicamos
por s sobre s cuadrada más 1
ok nada más los separe de esta forma
multiplicando estas 3 obtenemos la de la
izquierda así que multiplicando los
denominadores obtendremos también el
denominador de la izquierda verdad
porque es ese cuadrada más 1 al cuadrado
así que si queremos obtener la
transformada inversa de la plaza del
lado izquierdo
es lo mismo que obtener la transformada
de la plaza de esto que está justo aquí
ahora esperemos que esto debe comenzar a
notarse algo conocido para usted es
verdad esto fue separada en dos
funciones cuyas transformadas de laplace
ya conocemos digamos si éste es f de s
sabemos que lo que es esta función
verdad esto es simplemente lo que estoy
en marcando en esta es la transformada
de la plaza el seno de t y la
transformada de la plaza de esta función
es la transformada de coseno de texto
vamos a llamarle g desde así que esta es
la transformada de seno
este es esto implica que ft es igual a
seno de t y del lado derecho
digo debemos reconocer esto verdad ya
para estas alturas que del lado derecho
la transforma edad
deje de ti coseno dt es eso que tenemos
allá arriba no s / s cuadrada + 1 y por
supuesto cuando tomamos la transformada
de la plaza podríamos tomar el número 2
en alguna de estas dos funciones pero
bueno ahora déjenme reescribirlo de esta
forma déjenme reescribirlo de la forma
siguiente en lugar de tomar el 2 acá
separado lo voy a dejar dentro de la fcs
como 2 / s cuadrada más son acordadas y
digamos lo voy a enmarcar en naranjita y
entonces esto va a ser mi fdc y entonces
la ft va a ser dos veces seno desde
verdad sólo incluyen el 2 y ya ya queda
listo quería que quede exactamente como
fcc por gps sin ninguna otra cosa así
que esta expresión es el producto de la
transformada de la plaza de dos
funciones de 12 9 t por coseno desde
verdad ahora nuestro teorema de la
convulsión nos dice esto aquí
esto de aquí esto nos dice que si
queremos calcular la transformada
inversa de la plaza de dos funciones que
son transformadas de laplace puede que
sea un poco confuso pero quiero que vean
eso simplemente es calcular la
convulsión de las funciones si yo puedo
reconocer la verdad esto aquí es la
transformada de la plaza de dos veces en
oeste y lo de la derecha es la
transformada de coseno de t así que
justo estamos como esta expresión está
escrita
podemos tomar la inversa de la plaza y
será iguales a la convención de las
funciones originales verdad si se dan
cuenta va a ser igual a la inversa de
nuestra f mayúscula haciendo convolución
con la inversa de nuestra gema muscular
déjenme escribirlo así
efe dt es igual
a transformar la inversa de la plaza de
f mayúscula verdad
efe de ese y sabemos que debe ser
análogo no es decir g de te va a ser
igual
cereté es igual a la transformada de la
plaza inversa de nuestra gema muscular
de s
entonces entonces podemos reescribir el
teorema de la convención con
transformadas inversas y esto quizás
pueda confundir un más que ayudar pero
bueno déjenme intentar mi mejor esfuerzo
así que la transformada inversa de la
plaza de fs
de fs por qué de ese solo sólo estoy
reafirmando está esta expresión esto va
a ser igual a la convocación de la
inversa de fs con la inversa de gdc es
decir la inversa es perdón la conducción
de la inversa de la plaza de fs con la
convocación con la transformada inversa
de la plaza de nuestra perdón no era que
era g mayúscula de gds y miren no sé si
esto sea de ayuda o no pero si volvemos
al ejemplo anterior quizás si podría ser
de ayuda así que esto es fs déjenme
hacerlo en color celeste dos veces 1 / s
cuadrada más 1 es nuestra
fs del ejemplo anterior y la gds va a
ser s sobre ese cuadrada más uno igual
del ejemplo anterior así que todo lo que
hicimos fue separar esta cosa de arriba
cosas que conozco si multiplicamos
recupero la función original verdad que
estaba tratando de obtener la
transformada de inversa de la plaza así
el teorema de la convulsión me dice que
eso va a ser la convocación de las
transformadas inversas de la plaza tanto
de efe que es 2 / s cuadrada + 1 la
convención con la transformada inversa
de la plaza
de nuestra gds que es ese entre s
cuadrada más 1
y sabemos lo que son estas cosas verdad
ya les dije a ustedes anteriormente ya
debería ser bastante natural para
ustedes ver que esto es dos seno de t
y tomamos la transformada si tomamos la
transformada de dos veces en 9 obtenemos
2 entre s cuadrada más 1 verdad y esto
lo haremos haremos la convulsión con la
transformada inversa de laplace de esto
que es coseno de t así que nuestro
resultado hasta ahora permite ser
bastante claros verdad siempre es bueno
dar un paso atrás y pensar en lo que
estamos haciendo así que vamos a vamos
vamos a reescribir lo de forma más
concisa la transformada inversa de la
plaza de lo que estaba arriba que era 2s
/ s cuadrada más 1
que era lo que estábamos haciendo
originalmente que ahora ya sabemos cómo
hacer esto debería ser este llaves
verdad en realidad sólo se traduce en
resolver esta convención que es dos
veces seno dt
convolución con
coseno dt con coseno dt
y bueno dirás oye a lo largo de estos
vídeos ya se me olvidó lo que significa
sacar una convención así que voy a
reescribirla la definición de lo que es
una convulsión efe convolución con g la
conducción de ese con g es la integral
de cero a t df de t - tau por g de tao
dif respecto de tal verdad vamos a
integrar respecto detalló en este caso
vamos a tener que sustituir nuestra fe y
nuestra g de verdad en realidad
déjenme ponerlo con otro color esto será
entonces la integral de 0 a t de dos
veces seno de temenos estado seno de
temenos trabaja por el coseno de t betao
perdón el coste no de estado y esto será
respecto respecto de etapa y esto fue lo
que hicimos en el último vídeo verdad
fue lo que resolvimos o algo bastante
parecido verdad porque esto va a ser dos
veces la integral de 0 a t de de seno
dt - tau de menos tal por el coseno de
tau de estado y esto fue lo que
resolvimos en el vídeo anterior
justamente esto de aquí a la derecha
slacom volución de seno de t con coseno
dt verdad simplemente y esto lo hicimos
en el vídeo anterior
puedes verlo
para que veas la solución de esto y
justo aquí es un medio de t por seno de
t
ahora si esta es la conducción de seno
de t con coseno dt y si multiplicamos
por 2 obtendremos nuestro gran resultado
verdad entonces finalmente la
transformada inversa de la placer 2s / s
cuadrada + 1 al cuadrado será igual a
esta convulsión que dijimos dos veces en
oeste convolución konko se note que es
dos veces por un medio que se cancelan t
por el seno de t y una vez que
obtengamos esto ya ya esté en realidad
la clave reconocer que esto podría ser
dividida como el producto de dos
transformadas de la plaza que ya
reconocemos verdad esto se describe como
este producto que escribimos acá se
trata la transformada de laplace de seno
y de coseno así que la transforma de
inversa de laplace de nuestra expresión
original fue sólo la convención de cos
en ocón
dos veces en nueve si ustedes vieron el
vídeo anterior realmente hay calcularla
convolución no fue simple no fue tarea
fácil pero es una forma integral que
podemos resolver
en cualquier caso sale así que yo no he
demostrado este teorema de la convulsión
lo haré quizás en un futuro vídeo pero
esperemos que esto de mucho más sentido
de cómo funciona el resultado de cómo
utilizar realmente la transformada
inversa de la plaza y bueno recordemos
la razón de por qué queríamos hacerlo
esto es porque siempre es un último paso
cuando estamos resolviendo una ecuación
diferencial y podemos usar la
transformada de la plaza